[Music]
it is my great pleasure and privilege to
welcome all of the friends who have come
this evening to this special place to
salute Paul and Priscilla gray several
people will be speaking at different
points throughout the evening I will not
take time to introduce each and everyone
their names are in your programs however
there are a few very special guests that
I would like to introduce to you now
you're joined this evening by three of
Paul and Priscilla's four children
Virginia Army Andrew gray and Amy
slighter and their families daughter
Louise and family are missing this
evening but we think they have a quite
good reason Louise just delivered Paul
and Priscilla's twelfth grandchild a
little girl last Monday
I also want to note the presence of
Priscilla's sisters and their husbands
Martha and Richard Martin and Cynthia
and Louis Schuler they're good friends
Jim and Gladys Taylor have traveled from
Texas to be with us this evening
and all the way from Japan we are joined
this evening by our dear friend Michiko
Mitarai
and also her daughter Yumiko who
currently is a student in the Sloan
School welcome to all of you tonight we
are gathered to think about the
unthinkable Paul Gray leaving the formal
administration of MIT in the rich
history of this institution no one has
so graced or so personified this
institution as Paul and Priscilla their
images abound in the MIT Museum
photographed as graduate students in the
1950s gathered around Doc Edgerton zhh
piano singing with their fellow students
in the oft published photograph of Paul
seated on the bench in Killian Court
judge awed determined in their formal
portrait which hangs in the president's
house in person spied from behind
strolling hand in hand in the morning
toward McDermott Court along the walkway
which now has officially been designated
gray way is Paul the image of MIT or his
MIT the image of Paul both I suppose
indeed he personifies our institution
integrity loyalty tenacity and of course
his championing of our meritocracy
how fortunate we all are for Paul and
Priscilla's many years of dedicated
service to MIT we have heard this
afternoon and we'll hear further this
evening how many have interacted with
Paul and Priscilla as students faculty
staff friends trustees and
administrative colleagues I speak from
yet another vantage point that of his
successor president I count no privilege
of this office of which I am honored to
serve higher than that of having Paul as
a counselor guide and friend his values
bolster me his dedication to service
inspires me his perspective enlightens
me his optimism sustains me his
understanding calms me
his gallows humor tells me he
understands consider the time not too
long ago during a memorial service for a
valued colleague when undoubtedly with
images of financial pressures public
mistrust and sundry problems of
present-day federal university
interactions in his mind
Paul leaned over tapped me on the
shoulder and said wouldn't it have been
great to be president of MIT in 1956 I
knew what he meant Groucho Marx once
said that he wouldn't want to join any
club that would have him as a member
well Paul and Priscilla Becky and I are
humbled and privileged to be part of a
very special Club for which you have set
the tone and into which you have so
graciously initiated us thank you
[Applause]
never quite tall enough the Lord be with
you let us pray
gracious and loving God you hold all our
times and all our souls in your gentle
hands you number our days and the hairs
on our heads
be present with us this evening Lord God
as we gathered to remember celebrate and
give thanks for all that Paul and
Priscilla are and all that they have
achieved in their many years of selfless
service and faithful devotion to the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology we
remember with gratitude tonight all the
gifts of skill time energy talent and
commitment which my parents have shared
with this special and unique community
we celebrate and honor tonight what Paul
and Priscilla have been moved to give of
themselves their very substance the
blessing that they are to so many people
of such diverse interests and
backgrounds most of all Lord God I give
thanks for the deep generosity profound
integrity and thorough decency of my
remarkable parents I am thankful for
their countless small acts of kindness
their unwavering insight and
understanding and for their faithful
love and loyalty and raising their four
children in accepting and unfolding
their children spouses in their
shepherding of their 12 grandchildren
and in their nurturing of so many
persons encountered through this
extraordinary school Paul and Priscilla
have touched the lives and the souls of
countless people and have been motivated
motivated by an abiding sense of
responsibility hospitality compassion
and faith they have been colleagues
companions friends and mentors to so
many and so ministering Lord God Paul
and Priscilla have served your own holy
purposes and healing vision of what it
means to be a neighbor and what it means
to live in fellowship with you and with
all those whom we meet along the way and
so Lord God tonight we join with Paul
and Priscilla in welcoming whatever lies
ahead
even as we affirm
that has brought them to this special
time in place be with my parents as they
face the inevitable changes and chances
of this mortal life as they discover new
ways of being and of serving and
enjoying MIT and their family and
friends because we know Lord God that
nothing good has ever accomplished in
this life without struggle and sacrifice
we commend to your care and keeping
tonight all the disappointments that
come from being a person all the
hindrances all the Forgotten things all
the moments of sadness and frustration
we commit to your care in keeping all
the joy and beauty your grace confers
the love the delights the achievements
the accomplishments the hopes and the
gladness we commit in your care into
your care and keeping all that Paul and
Priscilla have done for us and all that
we have done for them we commit my
parents Lord God to your shepherding to
your healing and renewing to your
calling and making to your generous and
unfailing love bless this food and this
company and this celebration to our use
and us to your faithful service may you
Lord God of all be near us to defend us
within us to refresh us around us to
preserve us before us to guide us behind
us to justify us and above us to bless
us for you create redeem and sustain us
all and God's people said amen
[Music]
my name is Karl Mueller and I am a
emeritus member of the corporation a few
years short of twenty years ago two
decades ago I had the great honor and
privilege to get in touch with Paul Gray
on behalf of a Presidential Search
Committee of the corporation and it
really was a great honor and privilege
for me and my job was to see if he would
accept the proposition that we wanted to
nominate him as president of MIT and as
the saying goes after that it's all
history tonight we are met on the eve of
their departure from the main stage for
retirement the occasion is all the
sweeter because their performance over
these many years has been nothing short
of superb and that superb performance as
many of us have long observed was
engineered by a heartwarming close-knit
partnership of two people I used to
watch that partnership in action first
in the presidency and then in the
chairmanship and I must confess to you
that I had one of my more surreal
thoughts as I watched them in action I
used to think that the gray wedding
ceremony must have had a couple of extra
vowels put in there in which MIT
received very prominent and positive
mentioned
Paul and Priscilla the extraordinary
high quality and integrity of leadership
which you have brought to this special
place has earned you the admiration the
appreciation and the abiding affection
of all of us as you sail into the
tranquil waters of retirement you have
our best wishes Godspeed
thank you
[Applause]
I'm just so I'm just so delighted to
have a chance to wish a toast and give a
toast to Paul and Priscilla who have
been lifelong friends to Paul for his
years of brilliant leadership and
dedication to MIT but especially for his
foresight and good taste in marrying
Priscilla King and to you Priscilla
everyone would like to have the
qualities of being a president's wife
which you need but you're especially
endowed you've been a diplomatic
sounding board for your spouse while not
taking positions and yet being firm
you've been smiling and gracious as you
said goodbye to those 9099 guests that
you you entertain every every year and
yet dying to kick off your shoes you
have remained calm and totally poised
when during a formal dinner at the
president's house rat ran through the
open window I couldn't believe it when I
heard it
and now as president's wife you have
priorities to make every day what to do
family first
emergencies first students first
but you've always managed to make the
right choice
well Priscilla you do have all of these
qualities plus the fact that you have an
absolutely superb sense of humor and a
proven devotion to MIT in all of its
parts and and all through this a strong
sense of yourself I have felt always
that your purpose in life was always to
be there when you were needed and by God
for you always were but I have to tell
you something I have to tell you that
Priscilla has real grit and is a very
quick thinker one day she was walking
down the street and was accosted by a
student with a knife who demanded her
purse she gave it to him right across
the head and then he said lady what do
you have in that purse a bus stopped
which was going by and rather saw the
situation and stopped and Priscilla
climbed in without a glance without
another word and I just think that shows
something about Priscilla
so I give you two equally great people
but one who's just a tiny bit more equal
[Applause]
boy is she a tough act to follow my name
is Lisa Martinez and I'd like to
introduce you to my husband Brian Hughes
which is why we're up here together well
as with everybody in this room we were
students for four years but we're alumni
forever and you become a part of the MIT
community somewhere along the line that
community sense grows do you feel like
you're part of an extended family and
one of the things that holds a family
together is a sense of duty a
willingness to take up a task that
brings only its own satisfactions as a
reward and at MIT when duty calls it's
usually Paul on the other end of the
phone in 1992 Paul called and asked me
if I would testify on behalf of the
Institute in the overlap trial in case
you forget it was MIT that stood alone
against the Justice Department's claims
that the awarding of financial aid was a
commercial activity subject to antitrust
regulation well I was proud to say yes
when Paul requested that assistance
thanks Paul I appreciate the opportunity
I'm going to speak about another call
and a more personal call that really
wasn't on behalf of the Institute but is
something that made a real difference as
part of the family last summer we moved
to San Antonio ten days after the move I
fell headfirst onto a brick patio as you
can see all the king's horses and all
the king's men did a wonderful job of
putting me back together again
there is now enough titanium and me to
open up a small aerospace parts shop and
know before you ask I do not set off the
metal detectors in airports ten days
after the fall I returned home to begin
the slow process of recovery there was
fear mixed with hope and joy on
returning home as you can imagine I was
focused inward focused on regaining my
health focused on regaining my strength
well one afternoon Paul and Priscilla
called we talked Priscilla told me about
Paul's annual chimney cleaning at their
home in Rhode Island I suggested they
hire a professional that call their
simple kindness broke through my inward
focus and started the process of
reconnecting me to the rest of the world
and reconnecting me to the Institute's
family Priscilla
Paul your kindness did more for me than
you know thank you so I would like to
salute these two kind and special people
who bring such grace to this special
place thank you
[Applause]
I'm Bob man Emme class of 1950 as we all
do or should know beside every good man
stands a good woman for Paul that's
Priscilla my assignment was to
complement the tributes paid to Paul by
focusing my toast on Priscilla the other
half of this special couple the task of
course is made easy by the ubiquitous
presence of Priscilla in this special
place for now over four decades and the
warm enduring memories she has etched on
all our minds as she participated with
her husband and family in so many
aspects of the life of the Institute we
all have special remembrances I recall
several of mine during Paul's presidency
the way Priscilla remade 111 memorial
drive that we all just came from into a
real family home and invited the MIT
family into it student receptions
Christmas parties women's leagues events
and the gracious dinner parties that
Priscilla put on for all the graduating
seniors part of the process of
introducing them to their imminent
status as alumni and alumnae themselves
I got the opportunity to serve directly
with Priscilla when she and Dean of
Students Affairs Shirley McBay invade me
into becoming inaugural co-chair with
Priscilla of the steering committee of
the new MIT public service center in
1988 PSC has come
the recognized umbrella service
organization incorporating existing
groups and providing a focal point for
volunteerism at MIT monthly at our
meetings and in between under
Priscilla's thoughtful guidance the
otherwise all student steering committee
reported on their own group's
accomplishments and brainstormed new
ways of engaging more MIT students in
the self-rewarding
it's that accrue from helping others as
they devise novel ways to outreach to
Cambridge in Boston youth and other
community service organizations develop
new AI AP for those of you who are in
not coat not coat sensitive that's the
independent activities period January
offerings and engaged in the
never-ending task of finding financial
support this made possible i AP and
summer fellowships for public service
work undertaken by students and
sanctioned by local charities which
makes this a good time to note that the
need for financial support for PSC
persists raising and endowment through
the PSC fund in appreciation of
Priscilla nicely complements the ongoing
Europe fund to recognize Paul in a real
way while Europe inaugurates the MIT
student into early involvement in
research PSC introduces the MIT student
into what we all hope will be a lifelong
commitment to those others in need so
probably the best way to salute Paul is
also to salute honorary alumna Priscilla
King GRA 77 here here I don't know where
the glass is you have them
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening Paul and I came here
tonight after long journeys along very
different routes Paul decided to pursue
an academic career well I chose the
business world so back in the early 60s
when I was trying to learn all about
testing transistors Paul was writing
textbooks on transistors and working as
a consultant to a new england-based
semiconductor company paul's decision
and his subsequent career was wonderful
for students but less wonderful for the
semiconductor industry which lost out on
his considerable talents and energy
think of what might have happened had
Paul chosen a business career we could
have had a powerful semiconductor
company in our own backyard let's say an
Intel East Silicon Valley might have
grown up around Boston and all that
semiconductor money that now flows into
Stanford and Berkeley could be flowing
into Cambridge my company Terra dine
would have had a major customer next
door I could have been home more Paul
let's face it we missed out but hold on
maybe I'm getting carried away where
would MIT have found a leader for the
80s Paul and MIT were made for each
other where would I find a mentor and a
supporter for the job that I'm going to
tackle Alex be grateful for the way
things turned out Paul I consider it an
honor to follow you in your foot to
follow in your footsteps as chairman I
wish you and Priscilla a long and happy
next chapter in your already illustrious
life thank you
when I said I'd talk I didn't realize
they were gonna blow me up like I have a
confession I hated MIT when I went here
I missed my engineering buddies the easy
access to the professor's the constant
exchange of information the California
Sun of course to be fair to MIT at
Stanford I was an undergraduate living
on campus pre-split Nick and at MIT I
darted over to take classes in the midst
of what was essentially a building site
I was in no mood to be fair once I
finished my degree I avoided MIT even
though we lived right across the river
when Alex joined the corporation I
thought whatever just don't get me
involved
it was Priscilla who pulled me in I kept
getting invitations from her to hear
members of the MIT community while Alex
bent with the corporation well I thought
the first time she hooked me just this
once the wind from the Charles was as
unpleasant as it had been thirty years
before welcoming me to her home
she placed a cup of hot cider into my
frozen hand and as I warmed introduced
me to a number of interesting women
wives of MIT professors administrators
and corporation members we then heard a
marvelous presentation by someone
connected with MIT that first time it
may have been Philip Khoury or Alan
Lightman I kept coming back every visit
opened another fascinating aspect of
life at MIT most had been added since I
left but some had always been there I
had been too shell-shocked to notice I
began to realize that although MIT is
greater than the sum of its parts its
parts are individually spectacular by
the time Alex was offered the
chairmanship I was enthusiastic I still
have a lot to learn Priscilla makes it
look so easy but I suspect it isn't I'm
going to need advice and I know where to
find you
Thank You Priscilla you can run but you
can't hide
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm Betty Johnson and I would like to
salute
Priscilla gray as one who excels in many
things being a co-partner to Paul as a
mother a fabulous grandmother and also
an artist and a teacher in the field of
needlework you are really a tough act to
proceed aware of I speak because I have
known and worked with Margaret Compton
lose kill in Kay Stratton and Leia
Wiesner whom we wish could be here this
evening and all of whom have done so
much for this institute so we all wish
you many years of happiness good health
and good grandmother ring to your gang
[Applause]
it's a distinct privilege for Betty and
me to join in this farewell salute to
Paul and Priscilla as they move to a new
chapter in their lives at MIT this is
not the first time that we have said
farewell and toasted Paul's departure
from a post at MIT we savor the long
goodbyes at MIT we like the
time-consuming farewells we never let
anyone go I remind myself that it all
started with Paul in the administration
some almost not quite almost 30 years
ago when I asked for his help in the
administration at a critical time and he
began on his magnificent career of
leadership in the administration those
were the halcyon days of 1969 and 1970
some of you are old enough to remember
those days the administration was
short-handed in those times president
vest I have to tell you we were very
lean in those days in the administration
we had too many fronts and not enough
backs and we talked it over about some
major help talked it over with my
closest colleagues at Jerry Wiesner and
walter rosenblith ken Wadley constant
amenities we thought we had to add
somebody strong and resolute to support
the provost we found a wonderful
candidate
unfortunately she couldn't accept thank
you
we did find Paul we did consider others
we thought about some other rising stars
and the faculty Bob Solow John Deutsch
David Baltimore and isn't it grand that
David has steady work once again
[Applause]
and we're hoping that John can link up
someplace we in others but we finally
asked Paul
unfortunately god bless him he said yes
and he embarked on a career that has
been one of the most illustrious at this
institution as I've said we've had other
farewells for Paul and Priscilla from
time to time when he completed his
service as associate provost I think we
had a tea in the late afternoon and then
he did a great job in as dean of
engineering we had a kind of as I
remembered Priscilla we had a kind of a
potluck supper didn't we had and then he
did a magnificent job and the idea that
Karla worked up of a chancellor only one
other had held that spot Jay had held it
earlier but Paul held that position very
distinguished and we had a great
farewell there and I think it was a we
must had dinner for 15 or 20 people then
and then of course the presidency here
in this very room and you remember that
there was Paul in that back panel that
little boy and then he progressed right
up here
the problem with this ball is that all
that time you and I were getting older
and so we are ready to say goodbye once
again but not quite it won't end ball
there is a certain wonderful bittersweet
quality that you will find about going
from who's who - who's he
I think it was Bob a number of people
here
there are a number of people here who
have gone through that same process in
their own lives I think it was Bob
Bishop who maybe he's still here tonight
but he tends to go to bed earlier these
days who told me about Sarah Bernhardt's
farewell on the American stage the great
actress and as I understand it she
started out to give one farewell tour
but it was so successful that there were
many and the ads would say one last time
and it went on and on and I think Bishop
probably was witness to all that but we
say here tonight each of us in our own
way as you've already heard bless you
Paul and Priscilla your immense
contributions to this Institute both of
you together and separately your
constancy your commitment to this place
to our students and our faculty you're
sure and solid quality under pressure
your buoyancy in the face of dismay you
filled all the assignments superbly and
now we say goodbye to you as chairman we
wish you well we know you will have a
great time as you move forward to a
somewhat different but still MIT
centered world and we look forward to
other luminous and shimmering farewells
[Applause]
I'm Karen arenson I was a student here
during the halcyon days that Howard just
was referring to this is the second
weekend in a row that I've had the good
fortune to visit with some of my MIT
friends last weekend was the bat mitzvah
of my daughter and a number of our MIT
friends joined us in New York for that
and there we were sitting in a ballroom
a little bit like this one sitting and
telling Paul and Priscilla Grace stories
it was very relaxing and I can't resist
sharing one of those stories with you
tonight
that I think captures the spirit two of
our classmates both of them in course
six and both students former students of
Paul's have a daughter Rebecca who's a
senior in high school now she had never
shown a whole lot of interest in MIT but
last fall she began to consider it so
they sent off a note to Paul asking if
Rebecca might stop by when she came to
tour the campus the reply came back of
course have her call my office
not only did Paul take the time to chat
with Rebecca when she came up here but
he spent the whole morning
taking her around to classes sitting
with her introducing her to people and
showing her around the Institute she
went home floating and of course she'll
be here in September one more member of
the extended gray family membership in
that family is something I'm reminded of
every time I come back to the Institute
I can expect a big warm hug from Paul
and a big warm hug from Priscilla and we
compare notes about family and about
life and careers so tonight I'd like to
salute two of the most caring people
who've nurtured many people and the
values on this campus and for so many
years have set the tone and the
direction for MIT making it the special
place that it is Paul and Priscilla much
happiness to both of you in the years
ahead and may your family never stop
growing
[Applause]
good evening I'm Reed Whedon of the
class of 41 and I have a real privilege
to be here tonight and I have a special
message for Paul and Casey thinks that
the book of retirement has a chapter in
it that says you've seized from
fundraising he's wrong I know that each
of you can cite many instances of the
contributions that Paul and Priscilla
have made to this special place they
will both be remembered for all of these
when MIT specifically my classmate Kyle
Mueller and his committee were looking
for a successor for Jerry Wiesner Paul
came to my home on evening and said
that's a job I really want we talked
about the kinds of demands that the job
would make not just on him but also on
facility because as we all know it's a
joint undertaking but he said they
understood this and still wanted the job
Barbara and I have had the privilege of
knowing Paul's family Paul and
Priscilla's family and I just want to
salute both of them tonight for the
excellent job that they have done in
bringing up a fine and happy family in
the face of all the challenges at MIT
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Alex Dreyfus during the campaign for
the future we heard much about what a
great class the class of 41 was I think
it's time to acknowledge that the class
of 54 hasn't done too badly either we
might even know that some of the good
guys actually lived in fraternity houses
yes Paul and I were in the same class
but we really only got to know each
other during Jerry's presidency and it's
been a wonderful two decades of
friendship unfortunately I was in China
during your inauguration Paul and I'm
honored to be with you and Priscilla
tonight the previous speakers have
talked of Paul's many attributes - all
of which I say here here but there's
another side of the coin that is perhaps
even more important I believe that over
the years Paul and Priscilla have
defined the meeting of the phrase the
MIT family one of the best ways to see
that definition in action is to walk the
length of the infinite corridor with
Paul when the hall is crowded with
changing classes countless faculty staff
and students are greeted by named
knowledgeably asked about the health of
a spouse or a child or asked how a
vacation was enjoyed and Paul will know
where they vacationed to this day I
haven't figured out how he stays so
informed but believe me he does if later
in the day you have the good fortune to
have a quiet dinner with Priscilla and
Paul Paul will tell Priscilla of each of
these chance meetings and plans will be
made to call stop by and see or provide
some assistance to those in need I feel
certain that this genuine caring that
Priscilla and Paul have heaped on MIT
these many decades have played a major
role in giving this very
diverse institution it's feeling of
family Priscilla and Paul may you both
have the good health to continue such
wonderful ministering thank you
[Applause]
I'd like to say that these two people
are very special grandparents and every
year they invite all the grandchildren
that are over nine to come to MIT day
camp and at least once or twice after
dinner we have watermelon for dessert
and we have watermelon seed bites and
papa
is the one that can throw a seed the
most accurate fastest
[Applause]
they use the ones he throws usually ends
up on people's faces stuck on their
cheeks or noses and at camp we have a
lot of fun and Priscilla last year was a
camp with me she's my cousin and my
sister Stephanie would have gone to camp
this year with me but we're going to the
British Isles so we're not going to be
there this year
it'll just be Priscilla
I've just violated the first rule of
public speaking never follow the
grandchildren
good evening I'm Dennis boven and here
we are in this special place at this
special time and here I am one of the
last speakers just before dessert having
to follow Carolyn and Priscilla and
Stephanie and be sandwiched between the
towering figures of Alex Dreyfus an
outstanding entrepreneur and
philanthropist and the distinguished
John Deutsch Institute professor former
Deputy Secretary of Defense former
Director of Central Intelligence
I now personally understand Howard's
admonition of who's he
there is nothing gray about Paul and
Priscilla gray they are individuals of
luminescent colors bright beacons of
wisdom accomplishment friendship and
humanity MIT is a world-class organism
with great pride great achievements and
a formidable institutional memory no one
person or even one extraordinary couple
can ever change it alone but there
should be no doubt MIT is a better place
today it has been irrevocably improved
because Paul and Priscilla have been
here in many ways the analogy of MIT to
a raft in a fast flowing river has
always appealed to me once here you
quickly realize that you are surrounded
by currents much larger than yourself
and you learn to paddle together with
others but every raft needs a guide
someone who keeps the paddlers together
and looks ahead to find opportunities
and risks in the river that's leadership
and that is what Paul assisted by
Priscilla did and does so well I first
met Paul when he was my professor in a
key electrical engineering course and as
an aside a story that I'm sure Paul
doesn't know I knew Paul was a great
teacher because I asked one of my
fraternity brothers about him and he
enthusiastically if inaccurately
informed me that Professor gray is
terrific every one of his lectures is
better than the next
he became a doctor I met Priscilla at
about that time but I came to more fully
appreciate and respect her many years
later when I came to know of her
dedicated and largely unsung work as a
volunteer at Boston Children's Hospital
since those early meetings we have
shared many good and some difficult
times together but to most of us Paul
and Priscilla are and were and will
continue to be MIT Paul your inclusive
style your powerful intellect your
acuity your ability and your empathy all
continue all contributed to put a human
face on MIT we look at today's
celebration not as an end but as a new
beginning and we look forward to having
you and Priscilla as leading lights of
MIT for many years to come
thank you
[Applause]
Priscilla Priscilla I have a secret I
want to tell you I think our friends
here have missed an important quality
about Paul Gray he's just a hell of a
good-looking guy
Chuck vest said something about the
jutting jaw which I think misses that
unbelievable quality that that he has is
a man kind of a combination of Gary
Cooper and Albert Einstein
so much more attractive than some of
those who have preceded him what's the
name of that guy who was talking about
me earlier Howard Johnson
[Applause]
when did I first know and recognize that
Paul Gray was a serious person I
remember the moment precisely we were on
the squash court and I served the ball
up and as I usually do I went right to
the center the so-called T of the squash
court darted there as I normally do boom
I found myself sitting on my Fanny on
the ground
Paul had gotten there first that was the
moment I knew I was real dealing with a
very serious person I studied his game
and I realized that he had one weakness
and that has to do with the calling of
less that is contested shots when an
individual can say you were in my way
you're not supposed to be let's take the
shot over again
Paul was scrupulously fair about calling
let's needless to say I didn't suffer
from that weakness
and we formed a very strong and I might
say physical game on that squash court
well I worked for Paul for many years
first as dean of science and then as
provost and I can't tell you how much
good fortune it is to me having actually
twice in my life been deputies to two
men who I respect and regard more than
anything else the world one is Paul gray
the others bill Perry more recently in
the department defense but I can only
try and summarize the closeness that we
formed becoming as president and provost
is one brief story there was a tenure
case that came up sometime in three or
four years and to the time that we
served together and we spoke about it
late one evening and Paul and I were on
different sides of this tenure case
whether it should go forward or not I've
actually forgotten which side Johnny in
fact they've even forgotten the case but
what I remember with startling clarity
is the next morning walking into his
office and saying Paul I've thought
about the character of your arguments
and I changed your mind you're right and
Paul replied well John I've thought
about the character of your arguments
and I've changed my mind you're right we
were on the opposite sides once again
so I thank you both I thank you both for
not only the contribution to this great
institution I thank you both for your
friendship and your closeness to me and
what you've given me
there is really a benefit to having Paul
step down from his formal duties and
that's the one thought Priscilla and
Paul that I want to leave with you it
will leave more time for both of you to
have time with your friends like Patton
myself and we look forward to spending
time with you from now on even more
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
pretend you're freezing
so here's tutus presents gets to assign
unique right look outside the sun is
shining rights and contributions
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my distinct pleasure and great
honor to present the final toast of the
evening to Paul and Priscilla
doing so I would like to ask all of poem
Priscilla's friends to stand to raise a
glass
Priscilla and Paul for your love of and
dedication to the students faculty staff
alumni alumni and Friends of MIT for
your mentorship of all of us and for
your many years of loyal service to this
very special place we salute you and
thank you we have a gift for you this
evening you all may be seated I'm sorry
I may enjoy standing yes
this is a gift from your extended MIT
family faculty staff alumni alumni and
other friends this silk box and I won't
take it apart because it's rather heavy
houses two books one is a book of
greetings from many of your friends some
who are here tonight and many others who
could not be here with us this evening
the other book is called a dosa Doe book
a book of two sides one for each of you
on one side there is a tribute to you
Priscilla it outlines the Magnificent
contributions that you have made to the
Public Service Center and lists the
friends and admirers who have
contributed to the Priscilla King Grey
endowment fund since it was established
in your name in 1992 your abiding
interest and caring support is an
inspiration to all and you are an
extraordinary role model for the many
many hundreds of student volunteers who
serve the Cambridge and MIT communities
through the center again we say thank
you
[Applause]
the other side of the book as you might
guess as a tribute to Paul in honor of
his vision and championing the
establishment of the undergraduate
research opportunities program at MIT
nearly 30 years ago
today Europe is considered one of the
cornerstones of an MIT undergraduate
education and it is now a model for
similar programs at other universities
around the country this past winter we
established the Paul II GRA endowed fund
for Europe
Paul this fund seemed to us a perfect
way to mark and celebrate your
extraordinary service to MIT over these
many years it permanently associates
your name with the undergraduate
education in general and with this
wonderful program in particular you
should know that we ask everyone at this
party as well as many other friends to
help build this new foundation for
Europe with the extraordinary help and
leadership of Alex Dreyfus and Bryan
Hughes in particular we have made a
great beginning the book lists over
1,000 faculty staff organizations alumni
and alumni from all generations who have
made gifts totaling to date over 2.3
million dollars for the Paulie grey
endowed fund
now however Alex and Brian have reminded
me that the collections Department is
still open for business therefore I
should note that the books that are
actually in the box are first editions
we're in the process of producing the
second and final edition sometime after
June 30th at that time we will be able
to list all of the gifts that have come
in to both of your funds through this
fiscal year and we will include
additional letters and messages which
are still arriving from your friends all
around the world
this really is an extraordinary
outpouring of affection and respect for
both of you and for what you have given
mit now Paul and Priscilla it's your
turn to speak for yourselves please
[Applause]
it's with a very full heart that we say
thank you I've never seen Walker look
beautiful more beautiful and it's just
wonderful to have you all here
family all of you family I hope you look
at the flowers down front it's a little
bit of our beloved habit in Rhode Island
brought to life at Walker Memorial this
is has been one of those evenings we
never never never will forget you must
only believe a tiny bit of what you've
heard I have to tell you a little story
that I told the community on April 8th
when we were all here together for
another farewell celebration many years
ago I won't tell you how many years ago
I was a very green newcomer I've spent
all my adult life in this community but
I was new and I was green and I sat out
there in the audience in this very
wonderful hall at a party very much like
this for Jim and Liz Gillian and I heard
Liz Killian thanked people for being the
canvas of her sale and I have to tell
you that I thought that was a strange
thing to say but as I've grown older and
a little bit wiser I know exactly what
she meant you all the canvas of our
sails thank you
[Applause]
what to say our cups run over and words
fail this has been an extraordinary
evening
I must admit there were moments as we
sat out there well we wondered who in
the world were they talking about it has
been an extraordinary occasion and we're
grateful to each of you here tonight and
with you all those others whose names
are recorded in that book who made gifts
in support in the creation of this
endowed fund which will support the
undergraduate research opportunities
program that program as many most here
know was the result of the single-handed
creativity and tenacity and perspective
of an extraordinary woman who spent more
or less 20 years of her adult life at
MIT cut short by cancer I speak of
course of Margaret MacVicar it was she
who created Europe no one else some
folks may have supported her but it was
Margaret's initiative and it was her
vision and it was her tenacity that made
Europe an integral part of MIT and the
thought that you and others have joined
together to create this marvelous
endowment the income from which we'll
support in perpetuity generations of MIT
women and men who want to engage in
research activities under the
supervision of a faculty member for many
the most important part of their careers
in which they learn how to cope with
intellectual novelty what to do when
they find themselves at a point where no
one else has been before in the
intellectual landscape
that is an extraordinary extraordinary
creation wealth Europe and this fund and
were much indebted to all of you this
afternoon Priscilla and I were in the
audience for a seminar a symposium led
by Roz Williams the Dean of
undergraduate education with eight
including Roz eight participants some
students and some faculty and the
question they were addressing was what
is it that makes MIT education special I
found myself over the years
referring almost unconsciously to MIT as
a special place because it has for me
indeed been a special case a special
place a kid who came here 47 years ago
from suburban New Jersey to be provided
here with the opportunity to do so much
and to be related to so many special
people I'm not sure when that thought of
saying MIT this special place occurred
to me but somewhere along the way it did
and it began to be noticed and I find it
has become in a way that the thought
which motivates this evening and the
seminar this afternoon and I must tell
you tonight that for me there is little
or no doubt no doubt about what it is
that makes MIT a special place it is the
people who care about this institution
and the people who spend their lives
here who study and work here and make
MIT what it is mit is in the end only
people facilities
equipment history ambition resources all
of those things simply support people
and it is people who make MIT what it is
and who will carry MIT into the 21st
century as an institution an exemplar
institution of liberal education focused
on science and technology and I went
tonight to raise my glass and ask
Priscilla to raise her glass to those
people here tonight as representatives
of all those tens of thousands of MIT
when it men and women who are
accountable for this special place here
go sit down
I think there ought to be a little PS I
think that probably you the members of
this MIT family understand for us how
blessed we were when Chuck and Becky
vest joined us in 1990 and I'd like to
raise our glasses again to chuck exactly
now to end the evening I would like to
invite the corollaries back to lead all
of us in singing arise all ye of MIT the
words fortunately are in your program
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all and good night